Hey, if you haven't already got it. Get yourself a copy of answer the internet,
the card game it's available right now. And the link in the bio,
or you can get a Barstool, sports, Walmart, Amazon,
or Spencer gifts play along with us. Let's get into it. I'm Jessica Rhodes.
And I'm here to answer the internet.
If you had to get a lip tattoo, what would it say?
Ooh.
That's a really hard one Copenhagen
because I chewed for like seven years of my life.
[Inaudible] wow.
From Oregon is what we do. Okay. What's the weirdest thing you've jerked off to.
I can't answer that because my lawyer told me not.
To.
I could end up in a psych ward. Probably not a good idea. Just kidding.
Just kidding.
I don't know. That is so much better than answers
[inaudible]. Now, if I told you that I'd have to kill you.
What would you choose? If you could only guys, I'm also dyslexic.
So what would you choose if you could only have one of,
for the rest of your life, regular sex or anal?
Well.
I don't really think I have the required equipment for, regular socks.
I would have to say ammo.
Going anal. Yeah.
Regular sex is the easy answer, but we go for the Gusto.
Alright. Would you rather everyone be naked all the time or closed all the time?
These are silly.
I personally. Okay. So I.
See you at the club. Those girls people be naked too. Okay. Hold on.
Oh, okay. You see what you see what happens in life?
You change their perspective. You change the narrative.
Completely all the way.
And again, people might start going to the gym. They might live healthier lives.
In which case naked. If every time you finished sex, a song played,
what would it, what would you want it to be?
Oh, this is.
So, so many options.
Here.
Rap. I don't know. I don't like the.
You know,
I'm one of the few girls who actually truly enjoys getting calm on the face.
So that would probably be it. Thank you.
My boyfriend's a lucky man. Just putting it out there.
Would you date your dream girl? If for two days every week, your choice,
she had to dress like a juggler.
Uh, well, no. Um.
You take the good with the bad, you know, that's what relationships are
in order for you to live. You have to kill it.
What have I wrote myself into here guys?
Okay. In order to live,
you have to kill a blind child who has the greatest voice of our generation.
Are you killing the kid?
Will they see it coming? Probably not.
Right.
Is it weird for a guy to prefer lube Handjobs over blow jobs? Absolutely.
Like personally offended.
Yeah. Who does that? Like what are you watching? Jules. Jordan.
You need baby oil by the bed. Like come on.
Yup. Yup.
[inaudible].
If you could be any character from a TV show, who would you be?
The Punisher only because I think he's so bad-ass and that's totally what I
drove off to Frank castle all the way.
Just walk into a room and everyone dies. Like no music playing. You just.
[Inaudible].
Would you rather,
your girlfriend be able to read your thoughts during sex or all the time?
Except during sex, thoughts, thoughts, no thoughts during sex,
because then she gets something. Right?
I don't even have to tell you. You already know. Uh,
I told her my friend something recently, she was asking me about sex advice.
And I was like, girl, if you can't talk about sex, you shouldn't be having it.
My best friend's mom told me that at 13 and that stuck with me my whole life.
Would you rather be an extremely good looking paralyzed person or a hideous,
fully functioning person? A hideous,
fully functioning person because plastic surgery is,
it works these days. I, yeah, loopholes, loopholes.
I can find a loophole in anything actually at gossip.
The first time I danced there because it's not a full new club. Right.
They were like, Oh, keep your panties on. And I was like, sweet.
I have a pair of crashes panties, right in my bag.
Would you rather a get paid 1 million a year,
but have to work ridiculous hours or B get a hundred thousand a year for doing
nothing. I'm workaholic. So I'd have to say answer a,
are you choosing these yourself? Dan? You give me a good one.
Come on.
Would you rather see everything that has occurred in the history of the world?
Where everything that is going to happen in the future? Whew.
I feel like there's not enough Xanax in the world for you to show me the future.
I'd probably there won't be a future for me. If I see that.
Yeah, dead on site, especially the window way we're going right now. Um,
plus history just repeats.
Itself.
So technically I could save the world if I knew everything that happened in the
past. Right. I ha would you rather have a dog die every time?
This might be our worst question.
This is going to hit me hard right in the heart because I love dogs and I laugh
a lot. So this is a problem. Okay.
Would you rather have a dog die every time you laugh or have there be a genocide
every time you fall in love? I would rather the genocide. Cause I don't.
Yeah, I don't, I don't fall. I've been in love once in my life. So.
What, what would you want right off plan?
Um, group of people. Yeah.
Oh, okay. [inaudible].
Uh, would you stop masturbating of ever girl?
You jerked off to knew you were doing it? No.
That's a hot girl answer.
You know what though? I have to say guys, come up to me at events, no shame.
Or like that scene you did. Where you coming out of the Honda and you like,
they give me explicit details and they're practically rubbing their pants and
I'm like, I was, I was there.
I don't need you to tell me all the yep. You're doing it. That's fine.
That's fine. If there was stats available for every aspect of your life,
what one stat would you want to see? What does it mean?
So like, uh,
let's say you die and you can look at like how many times
you, how many movies you made, how many scenes you shot?
How many times you ate your favorite meal? How many beers you drank?
How many drugs you did? How many people?
Oh, let's not go there. Yeah.
Like whatever, wherever you put a number on how many mice you fed your snippets?
I would like, honestly, I know this is going to be like a sentimental thing.
I would like to see how many lives that I truly touched and why
All it takes is five seconds to be kind to somebody and you never know what
might make their day. All right. And let me find some of the murderer.
Would you rather be the best looking girl in the world or be able to read minds
Now?
I'd rather be the best girl in the world because honestly the stupidity level of
society right now, it would just be like reading a blank page.
Yeah.
If you had one free throw, wait, if you had one free throw and if you make it,
you got a million dollars. But if you miss, you never get to text again.
When you shoot it, I call people anyway. I'm old school. So yeah.
I'm a caller.
Would you rather be falsely accused of murder or never be able to stop coming?
I really don't know.
Like it doesn't yeah.
Ever stops. So you're just like walking around and come.
And you can't like focus, realize like how many endorphins.
Would be exploding in your brain.
I also told you that he would eventually kind of like.
Get used to it. No, I don't think so. How about we.
Do I get to phone a friend?
Would you rather have an Audi belly button or an uncircumcised Dick?
I'd rather have an uncircumcised Dick because they're great for anal.
And as long as you clean it, right, it's fine.
Why is that true? I mean, I just
don't feel horrible about the reading. No.
One of my favorite people to work with is my blue for animals.
Why w why was the circumstance? So it doesn't. So basically instead of.
The inside of my, I still get all of the pleasure without the you're tearing my.
Sound good. Thank you.